we have another caller this gentleman is
named Dan gersi he's from
Fallbrook
Montana Dan gersi are you on the line
I'm here with Jordan schlansky yeah hi
guys hey U hey Conan hey uh it's just
Conan not Conan um hey Dan how are you
doing well thanks doing thanks do you
have a uh it's gersy guu not g s RS k i
not y yeah I got it g e r SK y g r g e r
s y not e r g Dan not I Dan do you
understand that it's pronounced the same
so yeah I know but the the spelling is
the spelling is quite different I know
your producer was getting it wrong a lot
so I just wanted to clarify that okay
Dan I've never said his name I've never
written it I've never said it never even
heard it did he I don't think you were a
no I think you were oh a different
producer I think you were talking about
a different producer we established just
now that Jordan probably feels
inadequate and um uh and he dreams a lot
about losing his teeth and we realize
that that means inadequacy and that's
why when they said that maybe a producer
made a mistake he thought we were
talking about him even though no one
said you Jordan there are two of us here
one of us is a producer no Frank Smiley
is here producer uh you know so that was
that was my mistake I apologize Mr G
okay uh anyway you're calling from
Montana and do you have a question for
Jordan schalansky yeah I mean I'm not
even sure this is the right um outlet
for my my question I mean I mean uh like
I never do I'm a first time caller on
the show and a first time listener I
haven't listened to it before so well
this is the first episode we've we've
done of the show The Conan and Jordan
show so we've never done one before and
and quite frankly I'm not sure we'll
ever do another one um I'm seconds from
bashing his face in uh with a mallet
yeah but uh do you have a question more
and more what's that yeah my question is
it's again I don't know if this is the
right Outlet uh I live in Fallbrook
Montana about 123 miles outside of
Missoula oh okay and yeah population of
20 I think 29,000 small town but I have
an opportunity to work in um ramer's
garage and towing it's a it's a it's
like one of the two garage we have in
our town you know it's reputable and
they asked uh if I have any um you know
electric car or just newer car
experience and they're all computerized
now and you know I have I have some
knowledge but mostly I you know I work
with the older cars I have ratchet
wrenches and stuff but I mean I don't
even know I guess my question is how
long can I fool them without my
knowledge I mean you're being asked I
see modern cars of course have very
complex electronic systems and you're an
old school guy Dan you've got the socket
wrenches the ballpen Hammers um you've
got all the the tools that people could
use to work on cars in the 50s and 60s
maybe even into the 70s but then it gets
tricky so uh the question I mean like I
don't know I don't know if like is the
air pressure and the tires the same with
like a computerized vehicle or do they
fill themselves with it I don't want to
like start pump an air into a tire you
want to take care of this oh like a 35
PSI pounds per square inch but I'll tell
you this I oh thanks for saying that PSI
is pounds per square inch I don't assume
that everyone knows these abbreviations
I think people overuse abbreviations and
acronyms do you know what laser stands
for do you know what Raider stands for
Dan do you know what those things stand
for guys I'm just I'm just trying to
call get uh hang on a minute okay hold
oh I see oh Dan you're under the gun I
understand you've got a car you're
working on I don't know about the PSI
stuff you know I'm not measuring inches
and you know the weight of the oxygen
and per square yeah uh but I I just kind
of C curious about you know is there is
there something I can do in a garage is
there something that he can do in a
garage with his limited knowledge tools
with his tools my tools I have because I
don't want to be I don't want to be you
know jerking this guy around in this
chain and not kind of know how to you
don't say jerking this guy on his chain
you just say jerk in his chain
Dan not not here in F Brook oh no no
it's all different
here wait in F Brook you say jerking a
guy around on is chain that's one of the
things we say around here I bet it is
for sure you you never been to F Brook
I'll tell you that I have not I've been
to
Missoula I've been to Missoula uh
Dan Missoula is another uh animal of a
different kind man you're barking up the
wrong dog there okay well Dan I guess
what you're asking and Jordan is uh if
you're not familiar I mean maybe Jordan
do you think he should be working with
first of all are you is it is Dan in a
rush I do I have to answer this quick
like he's got a car but I mean why I
guess he didn't schedule this recording
so he had to deal with what he had
available to him but listen we you guys
were running I didn't think I would be
attacked like this but you guys are
running behind schedule yeah I mean
that's fair to say we are running inir I
apologize In fairness we are running
behind schedule and that is on us stand
and I apologize and you were supposed to
call with a question and talk to us
quite a while ago so you've got a
customer me I didn't know this was going
to be a blood bath pent I thought I was
just calling in you know I'm just the
guy from
B Brook just trying to get an answer man
I'm not you know I'm sorry jumping on me
Dan you know like I'm attacking him or
something Dan I apologize we kept you
waiting and I don't mean to have
attached a chain to you and let it
unspool and then um jerk on it so that
that you would feel the jerk of the
chain guys you know what I only called
in to try to get an answer about here's
my answer here's my answer for Dan all
right listen I respect Tradesmen more
than most people would realize I think
that some Tradesmen are masters of their
craft I had a Mazda RX7 in the 9s and it
had a hole in the muffler I need look
Jason I appreciate you know the
knowledge that you say you have but I
just need an answer I mean it's just
well it takes knowledge to give the
answer and there's a there's a reasoning
behind the answer that I second I know
I'm doing okay Jordan can I say
something
Jordan be he's calling in and you are
the host of a show guys you work out
your problems iron out your problems I I
can I I don't know if um I really don't
have time just yes or no can I use my
Stanley ratchet wrench can I fool
somebody like that I don't know that
you'd be fooling anybody by using a
Stanley ratchet wrench uh I'm going to
assume that's an American Imperial
measure not a metric measure
nevertheless you'll probably be working
on both foreign and domestic cars yeah I
think you can get to work there with
your ratchet wrench and if there are
Electronics or modern computer
technology to be learned I think it'll
be learned on the job I would support
this Venture would you write that down
for me I did I've got it's been recorded
I've got the whole thing um hey Dan let
me ask you did you feel like Jordan was
kind of I don't know what the
terminology you'd use uh I'll tell you
what I'd use I tell you that I felt like
he was impatient with me and know it all
yeah all he said know it all and he's
impatient the way he talked to you he
first of all he says I have great
respect for Tradesmen and then he
lectures you in a rude way which I which
I thought was insulting totally down on
that you're on Team Coco radio which is
a big deal by the way that's Conan
O'Brien radio you've heard of
him yes I heard I heard of you and I
never heard of Jordan but I figured
since you're there maybe I could
sidestep Jordan and just go right to you
well I
say yes I think you can probably
around with that wrench walk around say
some Bibble Babble and probably get them
out the door and get your money and then
later on if something goes wrong say
well looked okay when I saw it you know
what I mean see I I understand you know
I understand Jason's sarcasm but yours
is just totally
unappreciated what I was not being I was
not being sarcastic sir play back play
it back play it back is there a way to
play no I don't think that either not in
real time it's live Eduardo did you
think I was being not at all you know
this is a bit what are you talking about
this guy is like in like Los FES right
now you understand that do you think
this is clearly a bit is this like Dana
Carvey gonna walk in here right now like
it's Dana Carvey on does that sound like
Dana Carvey to you the man is a master
at Impressions I'm telling you uh you
obviously must realize what kind of
Comedy
this is clearly a bit oh yeah like yeah
okay yeah you know what Dan Dana
carvey's most famous impression is Dan
gy do you understand now that you work
in radio you're going to get callers
that do bits you understand you're
getting trolled do you not realize that
you're coming from the world of
Television where you're incredibly
protected now you're exposed you're
being trolled right now and you're
answering this man sincerely with I
believe no I believe this man I believe
this man exists Dan gersy from ask me I
is it ski or SK why okay and is it
Polish Russian was the territory part of
Russia or the Union of Soviet Socialist
republics or was it part of Poland where
are your where's your family from
gersi Jesus this is clearly a how are
you being so how you talk to people how
are you being so Gul this is a terrible
show this is the we're supposed to
welcome our listeners skerski respects
me whatever his real name may be he
respects me because I'm I'm talking to
now like an equal he's looking at you
laughing at you you're gullible you're
answering earnestly about the tool set
he should bring to work in Billings
Montana do you feel respected when
Jordan screamed at you are you near
Interstate 80 gersi in Montana how far
are you from 80 you're about 123 miles
west of Missoula did you say or was it
East you going to give me a chance to
talk you going just go babbling on with
your Mr know-it-all big words I'm asking
you the questions G
tell me the answer to the question first
of all call him Dan I took I made an
effort to learn his last name he clearly
is was important to him of course I'm
going to address him by his last name
well that's no is it ski or Sky cuz our
producer probably got that wrong too
listen to me boo you you tell me what
how I boo a term that they use in your
area of Montana excuse me Dan the Greeks
call it
boso
um Dan welcome welcome to radio welcome
to radio it's been 25 long years in
luxurious television and now look at you
here you got gersi on the line trolling
you you're coming out all innocent I'll
answer your question Dan I'll answer
your sincere
question welcome to radio friend well I
you know what that sound is go ahead
gersi what do you got do you know what
that sound is you're hearing I heard the
question what's the
answer the answer is how do you spell my
name how do you spell my name are we
still are we still treating this like a
sincere question what's what's the bit
here guys answer answer the man's
question uh I'm gonna say I want to make
sure you listening to the question and
you're not just running around in
circles with your fancy two- bit words
you sound like uh I'm gonna say you
sound like a what we would call a
gentile so I'm going to say you're ski
and I'm going to say that you're G are
because you just sound like a a u kind
of guy uh not an E con yeah Conan yeah
this dude be get canceled right away I
know call me a gentile he be canel right
away you you're call you're yelling at
him hey gersy hey gersi would are you a
gentile I mean that's no way to do the
inaugural episode I think you should
apologize you are you in on this you
know this guy no you should apologize to
him for that comment I uh I know you
respect respect me gersi for for
acknowledging what's happening here when
everyone in this room is oblivious or
maybe this is like all on me and these
guys hired this guy is this that guy
Hank Flynn is this that guy Hank Flynn
that we used to like get a writer job in
the 90 guys I'm gonna ask you the
question one more time yes sir can I get
away with using my stanle R set I garage
and towing that's all I wanted to know I
didn't want to this little uh you know
bratty girl girl fight around you guys
and just you know what I'm saying
well Dan I think it's time for people to
know um and I I I hope you're okay with
this that this is not Dan what
Dan you know Dan you're a real prick
sometimes you know that about yourself
don't
you you talking to me or the last
caller I don't even know anymore Dan
you've uh Dan J's actually uh
he's a yeah what's the
reveal me Dan gki what are you talking
about RK not iy Dan gersi happens to be
uh a good friend and one of the funniest
people I know Kevin nean Okay Okay Kevin
um what are you talking
about I'm sorry Dan I was just doing a
little bit here I thought Jesus when do
you guys stop with this
foolishness hey do you know but you know
Kevin nean don't you You' you've seen
his work have do you know him I know of
him no I'm talking to Dan Dan do you do
you know Kevin
nean he's the guy I'm applying for the
job for the garage okay all right okay
yes I do know him yeah well listen it's
been a pleasure talking I'm embarrassed
I'm embarrassed Conan to even say this
as Kevin
nean I never get never this my life
how are you Kevin you doing okay I
was well thank you for calling in when
are you and I going to go out you know
that place you love to go where I always
buy you the hash browns when are we
going to do that
again hello well hello anyone there if I
ever get off of this call maybe we could
do that some all right okay sorry he a
busy man all right well Jordan can you
say uh goodbye to to Kevin nean goodbye
Kevin thanks for joining you know what
there's a little red thing down here
that says leave and then there's another
one that says never come back again you
know which one I'm G to hit you know
which one I'm G to hit I have a feeling
I know which one you're going to hit
that's right I love you Kevin look me in
the eye for nothing all right bye
bye that was a fun little Excursion well
you guys pulled out all the stuff I am
honored you recruited a celebrity mhm uh
I'm flattered everything I said about
this being radio and not as good as the
podcast and there are um not as many
people interested in what we're doing I
take back because you clearly got uh
some of the big guns here to about yeah
yeah he's fascinating he's one of my
favorite funny people of all time and uh
hilarious he agree what did you
recognize the voice uh no I did not
recognize the voice it was good it was
good even after the reveal I didn't
recognize the voice but I give you
credit for knowing that uh well I mean I
mean uh it was a set up I didn't realize
you guys were in it um I I'll say
sincerely about Kevin nean um he's a guy
he's a dry guy which which is exactly
the type of humor that I love yes he's
very good he's uh he's he's sharp he's
funny you know what I'm going to end
this uh this episode here because I'm
going to say something you um you and I
we fought non-stop we bickered uh we
disagreed we shouted each other um I was
angry at you I think at times to be
honest you were kind of irritated and
angry with me but then at the end we
agreed that Kevin nean has a really is
one of the great dry Wits of all time
and I think it's nice to end on a point
of
agreement